hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt ich habe heute den zweiten
teil meines specials und zwar möchte ich
jetzt humus zu bereiten
humus ist eine paste aus kichererbsen
und etwas sesampaste und es kommt aus
den arabischen ländern also aus dem
libanon in der türkei wird viel gemacht
und in ihrer an und dieses rezept haben
sich ganz viele von euch auch gewünscht
das hatte ich letztes jahr sogar schon
mal angekündigt und diese humus passte
passt superkurze fleisch aber ihr könnt
sie zb auch einfach als vorspeise
servieren zu seinem vorspeisenteller mit
ein paar anderen orientalische oder
arabischen gerichten oder einfach mal so
als beilage so als tipp also das ist
wirklich so viel zeit ich das erzähle
ich euch aber später noch mal humus gibt
es übrigens auch fertig zu kaufen
das ist dann in so einer kleinen dose
und da ist ein praktisch schon die
kichererbsen mischung drin mit der
saison passte ich finde die kammer dann
noch nach eigenem belieben etwas
verfeinern also man könnte jetzt noch
etwas zitrone mit hinzufügen etwas
olivenöl und packe würze aber vielleicht
gibt es auch den ein oder anderen dass
es einfach so soeben mag mit diesem
geschmack und ich stelle es ist einfach
mal hier ab und zeigt durch die zutaten
die wir jetzt benötigen
natürlich brauchen wir dafür
kichererbsen ich habe jetzt schon die
vorgekochten aus der dose und zwar gibt
es das zum beispiel auch im supermarkt
in jedem supermarkt also nicht nur in
türkischen supermärkten sondern auch bei
globus bei rewe edeka und da gibt es das
natürlich auch das ist jetzt eine
packung mit 800 gramm und wenn ich sehr
abgetropft hab's noch 480 gramm
kichererbsen aber ihr könnt natürlich
auch selber kichererbsen abkochen die
müssten natürlich vorher dann eine nacht
im wasser stehen lassen dann abkochen
vielleicht habt ihr einen
schnellkochtopf fra geht es ganz schnell
aber ich nehme jetzt einfach die band
geschmacklich macht es wirklich keinen
unterschied
und so ist es viel einfacher für mich
dann brauchen wir natürlich etwas
sesampaste diese gibt es auch im
supermarkt steht wahrscheinlich im
gleichen regal und das ist einfach
könnte auch sehen oben etwas flüssig
muss man steht da natürlich gut
durchschütteln und auf türkisch
natürlich tag
und das gibt es auch in der
internationalen abteilung vielleicht
stets aber auch bei euch im supermarkt
bei dem zero oder so dabei wir brauchen
drei zitronen drei bis vier esslöffel
olivenöl 14 knoblauch ich habe jetzt
eine ganze knolle weil ich die heute
auch noch brauche aber das zeige ich
euch später wie ich die dann scheele
hier habe ich kreuzkümmel bereits
gemahlen
ich hatte den nämlich im ganzen so sieht
kreuzkümmel aus und das habe ich dann in
meinen mixa eingegeben und fein gemahlen
und hab davon eben zwei esslöffel
genommen
hier habe ich noch etwas frischen
treffer können auch weißem pfeffer ganz
gut nehmen und einen teelöffel salz und
aus diesen ganzen zutaten werde ich
jetzt mein humus zu bereiten
ich mache das ganze jetzt in meinem mixa
und ihr könnt dann natürlich jeden
anderen mixa auch dafür nehmen auch den
stabmixer geht ganz gut und ihr könnt es
natürlich aber auch ohne mixa machen
dann müsste das aber mit seinem
kartoffelstampf ganz fein pürieren das
würde ich nicht so empfehlen irgendeinen
mixa hat er bestimmt zu hause und könnte
es darin natürlich super gut machen
die kichererbsen werde ich jetzt einfach
abgießen und wert aber den saft
auffangen
den brauchen wir nämlich noch
und wenn ihr die kichererbsen sei
ist ab kocht können natürlich diese koch
flüssigkeit dann auch auffangen die
brauchen wir gleich noch
jetzt hätte ich den knoblauch schälen
uns gibt ja wirklich 1000 geräte und
knoblauch zu stehen es gibt so eine
kleine wurst aus gummi und ich probiere
jetzt mal was aus was ich neulich
gesehen habe und zwar schneide ich
einfach hier oben die struktur und da
unten die wurzel wobei ich glaub es
brauche ich gar nicht steckt es in dem
glas verschraubt und schüttle ich
einfach noch ein bisschen glaube ich
glaube ich hab's das trifft aber nicht
machen mit deutschlands meldet gut
aufeinander eingespielt ein super
kwick.de die nicht gestellt wurden die
stecke ich einfach nochmal rein und
schüttel nochmal und ihr seht alle
küchengeräte für knoblauch schälen
werden überflüssig
aber ich brauche jetzt nicht alle ich
nehme jetzt ich würde sagen ich nehme
sie drei großen wenn ihr kleine habt
nehmt a4 und die anderen benutze ich
später weiter also wie gesagt können sie
das wirklich in jedem mixa machen
ich gebe jetzt meine kichererbsen in den
mixer
da direkt drei esslöffel dieser
sesampaste hinzu wie gesagt ein bisschen
durchrühren und vorher schütteln
als ich oben gern die flüssigkeit
absetzt und ihr seht auch die konsistenz
wird dann auch fester das lasse ich
jetzt einfach kurz mixen
das ist so nicht ganz vermixt denn ich
gebe jetzt noch ein bisschen von der
flüssigkeit dazu da will ich es mal mit
so einer halben tasse beginnen also eine
halbe tasse und weiter mixen hierzu
drücke ich jetzt schon mal die zitronen
ich finde meine citrus presse nicht aber
ich brauche auch mal eine größere ich
nehme jetzt mal nur zwei weil das kann
man dann immer noch individuell
abstimmen
und da gebe ich jetzt gleich noch die
knoblauchzehen mit rein und natürlich
auch kommen also kreuzkümmel saß das
nicht dass die ganzen und natürlich
pfeffer genau wie gesagt könnte auch
weiter vernehmen ich habe es nur
schwarzen oder bunten dar und habe mich
jetzt mit einem schwarzen entschieden
das öl benutze ich später das benutze
ich jetzt nicht hier rein weil ich finde
dass sesampaste schon reichhaltig genug
ist und jetzt einfach noch mal kurz vor
mixen
da müsst ihr das ganze noch abschmecken
ich hatte etwas zuviel kommunen drehen
also benutzt doch bitte mal erstmal nur
die hälfte und ich neutralisiert ist
jetzt ein bisschen mit zitronensaft
es ist auch immer wichtig zu wissen
womit ich was sollt realisieren kann
also zu viele kommunen mache ich jetzt
mit etwas säure weg und schmeckt es
gleich nochmal ab jetzt weiß ich auch
was in der theorie news wurst den
geschmack ausmacht
und ich gebe jetzt noch ein bisschen
olivenöl rhein-main man darf jetzt mal
probieren wenn euch das gummi immer noch
zu können das auch immer noch mit etwas
sesampaste neutralisieren
also bei mir steht konsistent sind so
dass ich jetzt nicht ganz fest aber
nicht wissen dass zieht jetzt im
kühlschrank noch ein bisschen nach
denn dieses humus muss jetzt für etwa
zwei stunden in den kühlschrank ich
schön
ich will mir das jetzt in zwei schälchen
ab egal welche schließlich probieren
immer schön mit dem eigenen ehemann
alles gut schmeckt streiche ich das noch
schön glatt charts ich möchte jetzt
bitte dekorieren der kurie könne
deutschland mit etwas olivenöl und mit
ein bisschen paprika polyphon
klassisches süßes paprikapulver und
einfach noch ein bisschen petersilie
könnte auch blattpetersilie nehmen und
klein hacken aber ich mag das nicht so
ganz klein gehackt wird das denke ich
jetzt einfach noch kurz ab weil
ansonsten mal kühlschrank sehr stark
nach knoblauch riechen würde und dann
muss dieses humus für mindestens zwei
stunden schrank kann natürlich auch
länger ziehen auch gerne über nacht das
ist so ein paar tage haltbar ich weiß
nicht ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz genau
wie lange weil bei uns ist immer schnell
gegessen wird
aber ich würde mal sagen fünf tage auf
jeden fall und das passt wirklich sehr
gut zu fleisch aber auch ganz toll
einfach mal aufs brot mit frischem
fladenbrot sowieso und ihr könnt ihr
euch ja mehr anregungen
neben einer grillfeier holen das war
jetzt der zweite teil und ich wünsche
euch ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen
wenn ihr nach mehr konzepten sucht
könnte einfach mal auf diese bilder hier
klicken
da gibt es ganz viele tolle videos und
ich freue mich natürlich über eine
bewertung vielleicht könnt ihr mir sagen
wie ihr euer humus zubereitet ob ihr das
schon kannte oder ob das ganz neu für
euch ist und ich freue mich aufs nächste
mal wieder